quel est l'état d'esprit des soldats
Ukrainiens on vient tout juste
d'apprendre et je vous apprends surement
la nouvelle que la présidence
ukrainienne compte renforcer ses
positions à barmouth alors que l'on
parlait ces derniers jours
d'éventuellement évacuer la zone
ils ont déjà dit que ils allaient
envoyer des renforts vers backmouth en
réalité mais ils avaient avoué ces
derniers jours que le retrait de Batman
pourrait être envisagé si cela devenait
nécessaire visiblement ils ont décidé
que ce n'est pas le cas peut-être parce
que les positions tombent n'ont pas
bougé beaucoup ces dernières 48 heures
selon les soldats qui j'ai pu parler
mais pour revenir à la situation ici à
Limone les soldats ici me confirment que
c'est bien à backpood que la bataille la
plus féroce a lieu mais à l'est de
l'imam la situation pour les ukrainiens
et très difficile aussi les Russes
attaquent vers l'ouest depuis criminat
cette ville Limone reprise en octobre
par leur ukrainienne après des mois
d'occupation et clairement dans le
collimateur des Russes mais les soldats
ici semblent assez confiants que les
Russes n'arrivent pas ils ne parviennent
pas vraiment à avancer un soda ma même
dit que la situation ici était bien plus
difficile il y a deux semaines que
maintenant ce qui laisse penser que
l'élan et l'énergie de cette nouvelle
offensive russe qui a commencé il y a
environ un mois que c'est déjà en train
sur cette partie de la ligne de front en
tout cas à perdre en énergie mais on
voit bien que la ville on a souffert le
poste de police à ma droite j'ai visité
la ville en octobre elle était encore
intacte elle a été visée il y a 4
semaines environ maintenant elle est
presque en ruine comme une très grande
partie de la ville les gens oui les gens
reviennent et ils ont ils retrouvent des
maisons où ils peuvent pas forcément
aménager justement vous parler du retour
de ces civil qui qui avait fui à quoi se
résume maintenant le le quotidien des
habitants de Liman
alors les gens à qui j'ai parlé ont
répondu un peu avec sarcasme souvent
certains disaient vous voyez c'est le
paradis ici où ils regardaient autour de
vous vraiment c'est l'une des villes les
plus les plus endommagées que j'ai pu
visiter en Ukraine ici à Liman et
pourtant les gens reviennent pour la
plupart ils disent tout simplement qui
reviennent parce que il ne pouvaient pas
payer un loyer ailleurs où ils étaient
certains disent qu'ils reviennent parce
qu'ils sont attachés à leur ville mais
c'est une ville où il est très difficile
de vivre l'électricité la connexion
téléphonique pour la plupart de la ville
ont été restaurées le gaz est en train
d'être restauré mais une partie des
commerces se fait à l'extérieur vous
voyez peut-être derrière moi il y a un
monsieur qui fait des kebab qui qui vont
des chasselies à l'extérieur c'est
quelque chose qu'on a l'habitude de voir
en Ukraine en été mais pas vraiment
d'abbumeurs merci beaucoup Gulliver
notre envoyé